hi shannon
hi breakfast it's been a minute it has
real housewives of orange county season
16 sweet 16.
is it sweet for you
you know what i'm going to say that i i
think it is
it's a bit of a bumpy start
but
i i think that i'm in a good place
okay that's a a nice answer to here
because the trailer
it doesn't look so sweet for you no it
really doesn't
you're that's an accurate depiction i
thought we were friends
shannon i feel bad for you you're a
[ __ ] when you hear heather de bro is
coming back to the show
you know what you children are in the
house we're done please leave i'm asking
you
to leave okay wow
wow
what's the first thing that goes through
your head you know we started off on a
bad foot but we ended up friends you
know i thought we were you know as far
as i was concerned i'm happy that she's
back and
you know i think she brings a lot to the
show you know as i got to know heather
she's very fun like stay up late at
night and just laugh how did you find
out she was coming back how does that
news come to you well there was there
were rumors for months and so i would
text her
say are you coming back and she'd you
know do this emoji or say oh lord no i
would never come back you know oh no
please stuff like that but i thought
every time she sent those responses i
thought she's coming back i had some
similar conversations with her yeah i
think she was probably inundated
[Music]
hello
i'm back you've now made it through
two pretty big cash shakeups back to
back does that rattle you at all how do
you feel about the changes that come and
go with this group
well you know i
i think when i started the show i don't
like change
so it was hard for me to adapt to new
cast members and i did clash with a few
of them
i start charities megan look don't try
and paint me out to be uncharitable but
i feel that as i am maturing
at 57 um that i you know i'm more open
to meeting new people and i think the
last few years i have
been more open to that well i felt like
going into season 15
you lost the people we knew to be kind
of your oh i was on an island you're on
an island and then i i feel going into
season 16
you're a little bit on an island again
yeah kind of
you know what you yeah you're absolutely
right but see i felt comfortable that
heather was coming back and so i thought
okay we have a bond but yeah and season
the last season you know you're right
it's all a blur to me
yeah well season 15 was not the most
beloved okay can i just tell you we
filmed for five weeks
show was put together with five weeks of
footage we did our best but then did you
feel pressure coming into season 16
knowing the response that 15 got oh
absolutely you know but at the same time
i'm not one of the i'm not a person and
i'm not suggesting that people on our
cast
current cast are those type of people
but in the past there are those that
come on and say okay i gotta i gotta
ramp it up because we have to deliver
and i find that that just always blows
up in your face if you're just yourself
and you continue to be opinionated and
authentic
the drama will come 12 hours after
promising me it's not the sisterhood of
the traveling pants i didn't even
freaking know heather in the premiere
heather de bruyne she says she's has a
little trepidation about re-befriending
you which i feel was news to you yeah it
was when you heard that what did you
think i i don't know
i'm not as sensitive as i was at the
beginning but it still does kind of you
know kind of hurt your feelings a little
bit she also says in the premiere
heather that your maiden name storms is
fitting because you yourself are a storm
have fun
[Laughter]
i mean i'm gonna take
the definition of storm in a positive
way i like it yeah who who doesn't want
a little bit of stormy so you started
off you thought you were gonna be all
good with heather
there's a party in the first episode
things go a little left yeah i have to
tell you bryce it was not i mean
not the intent at all i mean
you can't honestly what happens in the
beginning of this season you can't
script i mean it's like
i i still
can't believe it i can't grasp anything
i am a very trustworthy you're not
no how are you gonna handle these at
least probably first few weeks of the
show airing where
the viewers might paint you a little bit
as the villain of the season okay thank
you for that label bryce
i'm just i want you to be prepared for
what is likely to come
okay i i you know what i'll never forget
this i i was labeled a bully after our
ireland uh season and i was doing watch
what happens live and i said to andy
like i'm just getting trash and he said
shannon it took me about nine years
to have this stuff roll up i think it's
taking me less time it's like you know
what i know who i am my family my loved
ones my friends they know who i am and
i would never want to hurt somebody to
make
information like that public and if they
don't believe me then
there's nothing i can do about it how
did this affect your rebuilding of a
friendship with heather oh watch and see
yeah it was no bueno but you seem to be
in a good place now
so i hope so okay
we'll see it seems like a little bit of
whiplash of you thought you were gonna
be in one place
she was in a different place then this
happens and then you have to rebuild
from there right it's kind of like
square one even beyond negative yes
square negative two maybe
um
in the trailer
heather claims that you told her not to
trust
gina and emily shannon told me that the
two of you were not to be trusted did
you say that i i did why it was a moment
you know
you're right about me coming on to new
seasons and not really having close
friends by my side so i filmed with
emily and gina i felt like oh wow have
we really come full circle i mean really
can we really be really good friends
together because i want to see the good
or i want to see the positive so yeah
dumb
dumb
you were giving jean and emily
a chance it sounds like where are you at
with them now we speak we're good what
does that mean i mean i'm really good
with emily
we have a lot of fun together this
season i'm
good with gina we all had lunch a couple
days ago so we're good okay we get to
see fun emily
fun emily with fun shannon on vacation
an unstoppable combo kind of
there's talk in the trailer of you maybe
being jealous of the bond that heather
and gina form
get jealous of gina's relationship with
heather
i have my own relationship with heather
i'm gonna call heather
automatic voicemail oh i think i was
just declined that wasn't a decline that
was a block how do you feel about that i
feel it's ludicrous
so but let's make a big story out of it
it's it's just you know i'm so busy
right now i am running my company i have
office space now so i'm away from home
and i literally schedule my day in
15-minute increments so i don't have
time to be jealous
i don't do you feel like some of your
cast mates take time to make things out
of nothing
um well apparently
now i do
i didn't going in but yeah i don't know
yeah i think sometimes people latch on
to a story that doesn't involve them so
it's like oh let's make that a big story
so i'm out
we've got some new people coming into
the fold this year
let's start with noella okay
i think that if you look at any cast
member who's closest to her it would be
me
she's the who she is closest to on the
cast
would be me that's a little surprising
given what we've seen and given what how
i
am with new people who would have
thought who would have thought yeah what
do we
as viewers need to know about noella
going into this okay well i believe that
she's an open book and she has a lot
going on
in her life as we start start this
season and
and i feel sorry for i empathize with
her
and uh it's it's tough
she's blindsided
and i can't imagine being in that
position
being someone who went through
a traumatic divorce on camera
did you lend her any advice or i mean i
i tried to our circumstances are a
little bit different i to be honest with
you i think
she was blindsided more than i was and
so that's why i have the empathy for her
and i still do have that empathy
she from my understanding was a close
friend of bronwyn
yes
how does that color
[Music]
your opinion of her going into this okay
well first of all was is an operative
word because i don't think they are
friendly anymore so i was
a little bit um
wary
thinking if they were such close friends
but i did find out an important piece of
information
that bronwyn told noella that she made
up
the
shannon said gina's house is sad and
depressing so i'm exonerated finally
i didn't say it it would be nice if that
was on your show yeah
yeah well i might have brought it up a
couple times okay we'll see if make it
yeah i probably won't
then we have dr jennifer armstrong yes
who i believe also
friendly with bronwyn
i mean that would be tough to bronwyn's
defense that would be tough
yes what's your read on jen and what do
we need to know about her as we watch
the scenes i'll tell you i didn't get to
know her very well at the beginning
uh
and my first impressions and i've said
this often
ballsy
ballsy
a go-getter
and uh but now that we've got to know
each other i we really get along i
really like her this season very much
feels like
the tone the energy of when you joined
the show
a little bit did it feel like that for
you yeah i think so
i think so and i think everybody
you know in the end i don't think that
everyone wants to
fight i think back to certain seasons
where and i was guilty of some of it
like i'm never going to forgive her i'm
not going to move forward it's like we
must have to move forward i mean i think
the pandemic taught us a lot that
what's important in life and holding
negative energy and arguing with people
that is just so silly get them back over
here i think that's right i didn't want
to invite you because you gave my
daughter pornography as a gift
when you think about this season that's
about to air what's the one word you
would use to describe it oh
gosh
i would say entertaining and i know that
might sound stupid but you're going to
get it all you're going to laugh you're
going to get upset you'll get frustrated
with people maybe me
so i think you're going to get it all
it's entertaining
[Music]
you